continuamos Ahora sí con nuestro segundo
invitado del día con el que vamos a
conversar sobre las propuestas de
algunos países para emplear en sus
transacciones monedas diferentes al
Dólar es el caso del Ian en Argentina o
la propuesta sin materializar todavía de
una moneda única que ha tratado de
revivir Lula da Silva en Brasil para la
región vamos ahora a conversar con Erick
Bear Villegas él es doctor decano de
economía en la Berlín International
University of light Science y profesor
del tec de Monterrey Eric Buenos días
para usted le empiezo introduciendo a mi
compañero Juan Pablo lucumí periodista
de economía aquí en France 24 Eric le
pido Antes que nada un contexto muy
rápido para ponernos en situación Qué
significa que el dólar sea la moneda que
se usa para las transacciones en la
mayoría del mundo a pesar de que sean
entre países que no utilizan el dólar
como su moneda
Bueno muy buenos días Muchas gracias por
la invitación tenemos que imaginar que
ocho de cada diez transacciones pasan
por el dólar por ejemplo si yo Quiero
vender un producto de Brasil a Alemania
tengo que pasar primero por el dólar
para poder intercambiar estos bienes más
o menos el 88% de las transacciones
mundiales pasa por el dólar Mientras que
el yuan chino solamente tiene un 4% es
decir que la dominancia del dólar está
muy clara Pero ha ido bajando muy
paulatinamente mientras que aumenta un
poco la atracción del yuan precisamente
por factores geopolíticos Y así
sucesivamente y en Latinoamérica
claramente se ven varios ejemplos
importantes pero cuando yo quiero hacer
transacciones necesito pasar por el
dólar porque la transacción directa por
ejemplo entre el RAM surafricano y por
ejemplo el euro es mucho más difícil de
lograr en los mercados internacionales
entonces uno se pone de acuerdo
utilizando la moneda mundial por decirlo
así que viene siendo el dólar Erick Por
favor hablemos ahora del caso particular
de América Latina de Brasil de los
movimientos que ha hecho china usted
hablaba de que la mayoría de
transacciones 8 de cada diez son con el
dólar pero en el caso por ejemplo de
China la la mayoría de sus inversiones
casi el 50% estamos hablando de un 48%
en América Latina son en Brasil Sí este
enfoque es primordial Además de que
China y Brasil pues son son aliados
principales en tema de comercio china es
el principal Aliado comercial de Brasil
y ellos ya empiezan a hacer estas
negociaciones en reales y en yuanes Cómo
podemos hablar ahí de desplazar el dólar
en este escenario
justamente es una decisión política
ahora con la llegada de Lula digamos con
este giro a la izquierda que se ha
empezado a vivir en Latinoamérica Brasil
siendo obviamente una de las economías
más importantes junto con México Pues
empieza a ver que esta voluntad política
lleva que Brasil haga esos cambios sin
embargo las reservas internacionales de
Brasil podemos imaginarnoslas como ese
esa base monetaria que hay para poder
financiar las importaciones decir si
Brasil quiere importar algo del exterior
va a tener que pagarlo con sus reservas
internacionales si lo queremos
simplificar así Ahora lo que han hecho
es aumentar un poco más las reservas con
los yuanes para poder también hacer
estos pagos directamente a China
tratando de de digamos de saltarse el
dólar Esto no es tan fácil todavía pero
si hay esa voluntad política claramente
pues van a poder hacerlo en algún punto
sin embargo pues muchos de nosotros
economistas tenemos todavía mucho
escepticismo de que lograr de que se
logre imponer el frente al dólar ahora
Brasil claramente y Argentina y también
chile que ahora está también generando
un acuerdo con con china lo que van a
terminar haciendo así como ha pasado con
Australia y con Japón es hacer
transacciones directamente es decir que
ya se pueda intercambiar el real por el
yuan chino sin tener que pasar por el
dólar digamos tener esos costos
transaccionales pero no debemos olvidar
que detrás de esto también hay un
componente ideológico geopolítico muy
importante que de una u otra forma es
simbólicamente un mensaje en contra de
Estados Unidos claro precisamente le
quería preguntar por eso que dice y por
lo que ha comentado de que hay
economistas como usted que son
escépticos respecto que el yuan pueda
llegar a reemplazar el dólar no le
quiero preguntar esto es entonces casos
excepcionales o se habla de una
tendencia Y aunque no logre desplazar el
dólar como moneda más utilizada en el
comercio internacional puede llegar un
momento que estén un poco más a la par
puede llegar un momento en que estemos
hablando de ese mundo Bipolar digamos en
este momento es el mundo unipolar en el
sentido que es el dólar el que domina
pero la medida que haya un empuje más
ideológico hacia este hasta dominancia
de China si puede darse fíjense que la
guerra ahorita es de la invasión rusa en
Ucrania precisamente ha llevado a que se
esté utilizando mucho más el Iván el
hecho de que Rusia haya sido expulsado
del Swift que haya sido bloqueado este
sistema de pagos internacionales también
ha llevado a buscar alternativas
Entonces esto realmente depende de las
distintas movidas geopolíticas que haya
y sobre todo que Estados Unidos también
en algún punto sea capaz de manejar su
deuda porque Estados Unidos está
alcanzando unos niveles nunca antes
visto de deuda es decir pensemos que más
del 129% de El pib de Estados Unidos es
deuda Y eso es algo tremendamente grande
que afecta obviamente También la
credibilidad misma del sistema de
Estados Unidos la gran diferencia
también está en que Estados Unidos tiene
un atractivo mucho más grande en
términos de China tiene un atractivo muy
grande en términos de manufacturas la
fábrica del mundo pero Estados Unidos es
también el centro mundial de servicios
junto con Europa entonces no es tan
fácil desplazar esto lo que uno llama
ese poder blando esta cultura de Estados
Unidos que también es tremendamente
dominante eso es muy difícil de
desplazar pero en el momento en que
estructuralmente Juan Pablo usted tiene
una pregunta más no sé si hemos vuelto a
perder la conexión con Eric o si lo
volvemos a tener con nosotros Ya volvió
Ya volvió otra vez a pesar de estas
interrupciones logramos llevar a término
esta entrevista Juan Pablo rápidamente
sí brevemente la última pregunta es con
respecto a Argentina porque también
entra a la ecuación Brasil como un
Aliado ahí también para decir de que los
negocios entre estas dos naciones van a
ser pues por fuera del dólar Entonces
como esto beneficia también a este país
que ha tenido evidentemente una crisis
de Divisas internamente
Yo creo que el beneficio con Argentina
es poco Claro porque Más allá de de
pensar que esta Va a ser la solución hay
que pensar es de dónde vienen los
problemas de Argentina Argentina está
sufriendo de sus malos manejos y su
falta de valor en la moneda tiene que
ver con pésimas políticas
macroeconómicas con una inflación de más
del cien por ciento con mucha
irresponsabilidad es decir que buscar
acá la solución realmente no va a ser
sino una forma de tapar el problema que
ha enfrentado Argentina ahora que
argentina se sube a este bus no quiere
decir que en algún momento china no le
vaya a hacer pedidos también porque
china Obviamente si se vuelve por
decirlo así este banco para Argentina va
a tener que pedirle en algún momento que
haga pagos lo podemos decir
simbólicamente financieramente pero
Argentina tiene un grave problema Más
allá de la sequía que ha vivido del
drama con la pandemia china obviamente
en algún punto tiene que ponerle presión
Argentina si los malos manejos
macroeconómicos continúan Y eso ha sido
una cosa que ya se ha vuelto casi
estructural en la economía Argentina
esto no será la solución para el drama
macroeconómico que está viviendo
Argentina Erika es Lamentablemente se
nos acaba el tiempo Muchísimas gracias
por haber compartido su análisis en 34
Juan Pablo nos vemos enseguida Ahora nos
vemos y ustedes sigan con nosotros
[Música]